غسان انت كنت مع باسل وكنتم مشاهدين على
اكثر من لحظه تم فيها استخراج ضحايا
واستخراج كمال احياء من تحت الانقاض خصوصا
الاطفال شو اكثر لحظه اثرت على غسان
كل المشاهد مؤثره سهام كل ما شاهدناه مؤثر
لكن اكثر يعني حاله كنا مرتبطين فيها لا
ادري لماذا بالذات هذه الحاله وهي حاله
الطفله عائشه تبعناها لاكثر من اربع ساعات
وزميل باسل كان يعني هو البطل والجندي
المجهول لنقل هذه الصوره ويعني الجهد
الاكبر كان يقع على باسل نقل هذه الصوره
للعالم كله وتفاجئنا بحجم كبير من الناس
اللي كانوا يعني متابعين
ومتعاطفين مع هذه الطفله عائشه تحديدا
فكانت هذه القصه يعني اكثر قصه اثرت في
خصوصا انه في هذيك الليله فجر هذا اليوم
كان ابني بعث لي فويس نوت يعني بيجهش
بالبكاء وبيقول لي انا خايف عليك ومتى بدك
تروح وكذا بعد ساعات اجت الثلاث طفلات
هذول اللي تبعناهم ما فيهم عائشه اللي
ظلينا لاخر لحظه حتى اخرجوها على قيد
الحياه والحمد لله
كانت يعني مشاعر مختلطه حتى بعد هنا
اللايف بعد اربع ساعات اكثر من اربع ساعات
فجاءت بباسل انه نهار من البكاء انهار
بشكل يعني كبير جدا يعني بجوز استمر لمده
ساعه وهو يبكي وانا نحاول نهدي عليه يعني
الوضع كان صعب جدا نعم
وفعلا يعني هاي الازمات الانسانيه اللي
بتلاحق الشخص وخصوصا انتم كنتم في قلب
الحدث لباسا لحظه البكاء شو اللي صار يعني
وخصوصا اللي انت عم بتصور هل في ضوابط
معينه انه بتقول لا لازم اوقف خصوصا انه
في ممكن قتلى او نجيب مثلا ممكن لو كانت
هي لو كانوا معطينا اشاره انه هي ميته
ممكن اني ما كنت اصور بس لانه قلنا على
ثقه انه راح يطلعوها عايشه يعني
لحظه انا يعني انا كان كل تركيزي بالبدايه
بالصوره مركز
بعد ما خلصنا نقل الهواء يعني ضلينا احنا
اربع ساعات ونص تقريبا
رجعت يعني كنت مركز بس بصورتي رجعت صورتها
ظلت في خيالي وهي عم بتاشر يعني انه عايشه
يعني طلعت انه صوره وكلمات غسان اثرت انه
عائشه عائشه عائشه خرجت من رحم الموت
فكانت فعلا يعني هي لحظتها يعني لاول مره
بصراحه بنهار مثل هيك